[Music]
113 question about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number two
what is the simplest known life form
according to NASA's definition of life
which we talked about in the last video
life is a self-sustaining chemical
system capable of Darwinian evolution
within this definition of life all sorts
of simple creatures are considered
living things things like viruses and
plasmids remember a plasmid is a loop of
DNA that can infect a bacteria and even
under this definition you could consider
a single gene within your own genome to
be a living thing now in order to do
this you have to think of the cell as
the environment of that gene that that
gene can reproduce and evolve inside of
and you need to think of the other genes
in the genome as members of the
ecosystem that that gene is evolving
inside of it's a really strange way to
think about genes but you can think of a
gene a single gene in your genome as a
living creature this is actually a
really productive way to think about
genes under certain circumstances
Richard Dawkins actually wrote an entire
book about this called The Selfish Gene
where he encourages people to think more
about genes as if they are living
creatures the the basic units of
evolution one of the things about genes
is that they're locked into cooperation
with the other genes in their genome and
they really only reproduce or replicate
when the entire genome and in fact the
entire cell is reproducing so they're
they're kind of locked into cooperation
there are ways that a gene can break
free from that cooperation and start to
reproduce on its own independently of
the cell and independently of the other
genes but that's kind of a special
circumstance the simplest independent
living creature that we know of that we
discovered so far would have to be the
vibrate so earlier we talked about
plasmids these loops of DNA that can
evolve and replicate inside of bacteria
well a vibrate is even simpler than that
a viroid is a loop of RNA
it's a single-stranded loop of RNA that
replicates inside of plant cells now in
order to understand how viroids work
it's really important that you
understand what DNA is what RNA is what
nucleotides are and what base pairing is
so if you happen to be a little bit
foggy on any of those topics put this
video on pause and go watch two
animations that I did on my other
channel stated clearly one of them is
what is DNA and how does it work and the
other is what is the RNA world
hypothesis I have links to them in the
video description so go watch those and
then come back because we are about to
learn something amazing about viroids
these are fascinating fascinating
creatures this is the potato spindle
tuber viroid we know every nucleotide
that makes up its genome if you could
even call it a genome it was discovered
recently just in 1971 by dr. Theodore
dinner and as I'm sure you can imagine
this Virant is constantly evolving so
different individuals vary in length and
in sequence but this is the sequence the
typical sequence that this viroid is
found in it's normally about 360
nucleotides long it's a big long loop
and it's a squashed loop and the reason
it's a squashed loop is because it base
pairs with itself
it's a single-stranded chain of RNA but
usually when you have a single-stranded
chain of RNA it's not just open and
loose it always folds up in base pairs
with itself vibe roads are extremely
fascinating because they do not use the
genetic code they're the only organisms
we know of that don't use the genetic
code now they do use a protein that
plants code for using the genetic code
but the viroid itself doesn't know the
genetic code doesn't speak the genetic
code it doesn't make proteins it doesn't
code for proteins what it does instead
is it gets inside of a plant cell in
this case a potato cell and it
chemically attracts a protein called RNA
polymerase 2 this is a diagram of RNA
polymerase 2 and what this enzyme does
this protein does is it attaches to the
viroid and it starts making copies of it
it takes RNA nucleotides that the cells
produced and it uses those nucleotides
to make copies
of the viroid and it does this over and
over and over again thousands and
thousands and thousands of copies of the
vibrator made this way and that is how
viroids make a living they steal a
protein from a plant cell and they spill
nucleotides from a plant cell and they
just make copies of themselves so there
you have it
viroids they are the simplest known
creatures on planet Earth
in fact they are the simplest known
creatures and all of the cosmos next
question